hey everyone Persia here and if you
didn't already know I'm completely
obsessed with Animal Crossing New
Horizons
however there's so much more to be
obsessed about than just the game itself
the community has been killing it with
their custom designs recreations and
complete works of art when it comes to
their islands every week I'll feature
some amazing community creations Islands
codes and all we're kicking things off
with something simple but crucial to
giving that extra bit of flair to your
Island let's check out this week's best
path designs and New Horizons first up
we have this amazing black brick road
design by at meow you died you have the
standard red brick design in your island
designer app but no other color options
to choose from
I've seen some pink white and even
rainbow brick designs so far but there's
just something so sleek and beautiful
about this design that immediately stood
out and made me wish I had more design
slots available I'm sure you've run into
areas on your island where you wish the
path tool would just make some diagonal
lines or you don't want to terraform
everything to match a path well with at
love slime lines IV brick path not only
do you get a very pretty IV brick design
but you'll also be able to reach those
very weird corners without compromising
your seamless path
the next few designs are the perfect fix
for any path that you deem a little too
rough around the edges
if you've laid down a standard path and
you may have noticed that the edges of
those paths leave something to be
desired
that's where curbstones has come to save
us at Toria pink lotus has made these
curb stones that match gracefully with
the stone path for those of you like me
who have an odd preference for bricks
then at UDC has you covered there and
finally go from terracotta to terra
gotta have those curb stones thanks to
add Melissa senpai I've seen a few
different variations so far but when it
comes to classic roads I really like the
clean and thoughtful layout of at type
vs. Street designs they come with
crosswalks in even edges that drift
perfectly into the rest of your island
if need be straight paths and new
horizons have been used to make some
gorgeous cityscapes and Street markets
already and I can't wait to see what
else can be done
do you have one you'd like to share
please do so below alright time to head
back to the woods because our next path
is a pair of beautiful wood stumps that
actually come in two colors brown and
white besides the fact that they're very
aesthetically pleasing there are only
two patterns for each color which will
add variety but won't eat up all those
precious design slots chat up to at kaya
underscore Animal Crossing for the
amazing art and the thoughtful
functionality our last entry of the week
is not exactly a path but a path plaque
creator at big chests lappa gives you an
adorable alternative to those signposts
with six variations in total you can
keep your town organized labelled and
looking sleek with these plaques next
time we'll be taking a look at some of
the best islands we've seen so far you
can download any of these paths yourself
with the codes listed below but don't
forget to share with us how you've
enhanced your Island with them if you do
if you like what you saw and want to
learn more about custom designs you
should check out our custom design
guides that we have up on our channel
right now thanks for watching and hit me
up if you've got some good turn up
prices
[Music]